what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch from
the wheel of time official teaser
trailer this has a previously
established intellectual property you
know a book what let's watch
[Music]
this the wheel of time turns
and ages come and pass
leaving memories
cool it's beautiful
this is the prelude for the lord of the
rings seriously
ice and god
rosamund pike
the force
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
the wheel keeps turning
all the colors man
whatever happens now
there's no turning back
[Music]
those two notes
i know i know it's based on its own book
series a book series that full
disclosure john and i have not read
ourselves don't lie on my behalf i'm a
huge wheel of time huge wheel of time
fat so all we can do is judge it off the
trailer alone i'm gonna judge this
little fact right now as we're watching
this it has it's probably changed by the
time this is uploaded 950 000 views 33k
likes 1.2 dislikes i'm wondering a
is that from them changing stuff in the
book that is clearly apparent here in
the trailer or b
that one line about women touching stuff
is being the saviors who woke up what is
it what do you think it is
stop the feminism burns what i'll
what i'll say though is there's actually
something kind of refreshing to me about
that you know like i don't know if it's
in the book or not but forgetting a
fantasy series like this and even with
fantasy movies usually that line is if
men congratulate yeah it's always it's
usually meant
and it does create something actually
kind of refreshing in its aesthetic and
this fantasy piece just with that
context alone
so i'm i'm actually all for it that's
cause i'm a woke talk yeah you white
knight over here
all you do is just chill for the
feminists that being said uh i mean i
think the show has a wonderful looking
production value i think roosevelt pike
is uh kind of an underrated actress
and it looks really well produced
they're really well made it's just a
teaser trailer so i don't know
everything it's supposed to sell you on
the you know the landscape the wonder
the lush beauty beholden to us and i
think there's some really cool uh color
and framing that they do here especially
with the trailer editing when you're
match cutting on moving shots i think is
really cool at the same time
there are there are things about it that
just look aesthetically just very
derivative of a bunch of things i've
seen already and that's kind of uh the
issue i have with it was as grandiose as
it is and as as fantastical and big and
i'm sure book readers i'm sure
that you guys will be like oh no it's
this story this story is what makes it
different you guys can comment but in
terms of a person who hasn't read the
book and i imagine most who watch this
trailer are non-readers too you do have
to sell them on it and right now it
looks like yeah it actually
looks like somewhere in the middle
between
game of thrones and a and one of those
like fantasy abc shows
yeah i get you there and where are we
going to ultimately fall and is that
going to be the abc in terms of
storytelling or in terms of the
production yeah here i mean it looks i
was funny i was thinking like man that
lord of the rings show must be going to
look pretty terrific because this looks
pretty terrific at least in terms of
yeah scale and production values and the
locations and what look to be some sets
as well as a bunch of cgi stuff like it
looks really big and broad and scopic
and dazzling that way and then yeah
luckily this is a teaser trailer so
they're not hitting you with too much
story too many scenes but that's yeah
the big thing now is i'm like okay is
this going to feel you know like a
melodrama wrapped around in an epic
world packaging or you know is this
going to reach those epic heights that
you hope it could and it certainly seems
like it has the potential to this whole
thing is like potential to the max
absolutely then it just comes down to
how they handle you know the true themes
of the story that you know you readers
are probably much more familiar with
than we are right now i thought it was
interesting the way it was composed of
how close everything was i don't know
what lens they're using for this usually
i imagine with fantasy stuff
everything's kind of more in a wide
frame because you want to soak in all of
that yeah but everything was kind of in
this square frame like more like
standard versus widescreen is kind of
like the basic terminology i can go for
here vhs versus laserdisc
that kind of flare was something that uh
threw me by surprise because yeah i feel
like this could easily land into just
like a remarkably cheesy territory or it
could be something awesome because yeah
i was even thinking of like some witcher
i was thinking of thinking about vikings
vikings lord of the rings golden compass
there's like some harry potter sprinkled
around the frame and then the thing is i
mean so many of these novels you know
that i don't know when this is published
yeah it's like you have this hodgepodge
of just various tropes and ideas and
stuff but there was still nothing here
that gripped me as this looks entirely
unique i mean i did like all the
you know diversity of faces that we got
here though which was cool to see it
usually is white folk in these movies
and stuff you know the fantasy crew
it
usually is so uh to see like oh you got
like a black person here you got asian
people here that's cool who would have
thought they existed
they existed at the times when they made
these movies doesn't take place in just
the white people kingdom yeah so i like
seeing the diversity uh on display i'm
still looking for something that really
gives me that this this is very there's
something fresh in its tone and or or
storytelling here yeah like i have to
see what this is going to say because
right now it's playing on i like those
other things
this looks just as high profile as those
other things yeah i feel like it would
be a disservice if i was to like try to
wikipedia what happens in the book to
watch this trailer yeah but as far as
we're going you know amazon is pretty
reliable with the shows they really put
front and center for what they're
marketing obviously through a lot of
money at this and this does sort of feel
like let's get this down as well when we
got lord of the rings going on so we
could be like
the network for go-to fan or the
streaming service for go-to fantasy
shows yeah epic fantasy network yeah
yeah you kind of get that vibe but guys
what did you think about this trailer
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe click that bell hit that
like button and last but not least
adelia chamberlain adelia is probably
the biggest bookworm over at our patreon
page and adelia is actually coming to
los angeles this month attending the
showdown spectacular so i was like okay
maybe i'll go to the showdown
spectacular then did i really want to
i'd like to be invited but to say no
yeah that's what i want for most things
but i guess
i'll do my best to go just so i can say
hi to you adelia we'll sneak in let's
just say hi for some reason these things
christian heart luck still charges us
yeah he charges us extra it's weird
and then he makes us set up things on
the stage but it'll all be worth it for
you adelia he keeps saying it'll be
worth it in the end yeah like
when does it end what what is coming
what is coming in geez don't keep us in
the dark so we're going to suffer for
you yeah yeah and if you can find out
from christian and tell us beforehand
then we don't even have to to do all
that you know we could just meet out
front and hang out there
adelia
[Music]